[Musique]
les québécois
nous on est maintenant de toilette
j'ai fait d'innombrables théories sur
star wars sur kei lorraine surstocks
fine et même roanne mais nous n'avons
jamais parlé de théories sur la saga en
elle-même et vu que vous avez explosé
les votes pour star wars aussi un tout
nouveau trois théories sur une saga
jamais culte dans le monde entier et
dans mon coeur
bien évidemment j'ai essayé de vous
trouver des théories original
convaincante est possible allez c'est
parti
l'un des personnages les plus stylés et
surpuissant nous avons parlé de darse
mauvais comme vous le savez bien d'art
small est ainsi très puissant apprentis
de palpatine est tué par obi wan dans le
tout premier film après un rude combat
ouvrit ron moore a d'ailleurs si vous
aimez réellement ce personnage je vous
conseille cette funk fi ction sur lui
vraiment très impressionnante
mais revenons ont fait et si d'art small
avait survécu
je m'explique dans le film nous voyons
clairement d'art small mourir il est
coupé en deux et tombe au fin fond d'un
trou comme palpatine à la fin du 6 mai
dans clone wars
il est dit qu'obi wan a seulement coupé
les jambes de ce protagoniste et
qu'ensuite dans sa survie à tout prix
d'art small s'est créé des jambes
robotique a règné temporairement pour
ensuite avoir de vraies jambes
robotisées
oui ces traits tirés par les cheveux
mais pas tant que ça au final pourquoi
quel sort a subi anakin il a eu les
jambes coupées le bras et fut calciné
suite à son combat contre obi wan
mais il est toujours en vie et devient
très robotisée avec le nom de dark vador
on ne montre pas ce qu'est devenu d'art
small suite à sa chute il était
surpuissant il est possible qu'il ait
réussi à survivre grâce à la force
les corps at il fait suite à sa survie
il serait devenu boba fett et c'est là
le coeur de la théorie d'ars maul serait
boba fett bien évidemment nous supposons
qu'il reviendrait en tant que site mais
ne serait pas boba fett depuis le début
mars on l'aurait tué boba fett et aurait
pris sa place pour se cacher de
palpatine
de plus d'après une autre théorie boba
fett aurait tué l'oncle de l'udc
owen il se pourrait que ce soit lui qui
ait tué les proches du jeune garçon pour
le pousser à accomplir sa destinée est
allé affronter palpatine pour se venger
de sa défaite
de plus la voix son bras robotisé de
boba fett nous rappelle étrangement ça
alors combien que cette théorie n'est
pas la meilleure mais je vais trouver
intéressante et je voulais absolument
parler de darth maul que j'adore après
tout d'art small était un très bon élève
il serait capable de survivre à
n'importe quelle situation étudie
toujours très bien ses ennemis pour
mieux les tuer bref n'hésitez pas à me
dire ce que vous en pensez
cette théorie est très connu mais
tellement probable couayron fut le
maître d'obi-wan kenobi et celui qui
découvrait le petit anakin sur la
planète de tatouine cependant ce dernier
mourra façades art small avec les
honneurs d'un des plus grands jedi de la
galaxie néanmoins quoique jean n'est pas
un jedi comme les autres malgré sa
grande sagesse et sa maîtrise complète
de la force énormément de fans affirment
que ce dernier était un seigneur sith
infiltrés pourquoi une prophétie chez
les jedi parle d'un enfant et lui qui en
grandissant apporterait l'equilibre dans
la force en tuant les sites gones en
trouvant un akin sur tatooine découvrir
en lui un taux de midi clos rien
impressionnant et qu'ils étaient
destinés à avoir une très grande
maîtrise de la force
cependant comme vous le savez anakin est
devenu le célèbre seigneur sith dark
vador où je veux en venir c'est que
cauet gaulle jean impossiblement su can
hacking deviendrait dark vador
il insista près du conseil jedi
lourdement pour khanaqinne devienne un
jedi
quitte à l'entraîner lui même alors
qu'il avait déjà comme apprenti obi wan
le conseil avait perçu en anakin déjà
une grande sombres heures
d'ailleurs quoi gones n'était pas à sa
première assurance envers le conseil et
bizarrement l'un des plus grands jedi
québécois hugo nomura façades art small
en combat singulier laissant obi-wan
jeunes et influençable avec le petit
anakin sans maison il était fort c'est
que ce dernier prit un akin sous son
aile pour l'entraîner lui enseigner la
force en l'honneur de son maître
couayron qui sut lui rappeler avant de
mourir d'entraîner le garçon rigole jean
se serait laissé tuer par darth maul
pour qu'obi wan face devenir anakin un
grand jedi et accessoirement un grand
site
de plus le comte dooku si vous rappelez
bien et l apprenti de maître yoda et le
maître jedi de quoi gones jean cependant
ce dernier a mal tourné et n'a pas
hésité à devenir un site
obéissant à dark sidious il serait
fortement probable que kouagou jean
appelé aussi le jedi grille soit un site
infiltrés
[Musique]
cette théorie a été tourné et retourné
mais j'aimerais vous expliquer ma propre
version de celle ci anakin a toujours
été perçu comme un jedi avec une
certaine haine en lui qui ça prouvera
suite à la mort de sa mère toute
l'histoire de star wars 3 tourne autour
de palpatine qui essaye d'amener anakin
vers le côté obscur
jusqu'à se servir de sa peur de perdre
pad mais je rappelle khanaqinne à des
visions de palme est en train de mourir
je suis sûr que ces visions sont
l'oeuvre de palpatine qui a très bien
compris les souffrances du john jay
taille de plus palpatine aussi appelé
sidious n'hésite pas à raconter sa
propre histoire avec son ancien maître
d'art ce plugin lesage maîtrisant la
force avec une telle puissance qu'il
pouvait contrôler la vie et la mort
il est d'ailleurs certainement le père
d'anakin mais on en reparlera dans une
autre vidéo si vous souhaitez palpatine
connaît donc les pratiques de son maître
qui lui a tout appris où je veux en
venir c'est que dans le film il est dit
que pad mais avant de mourir était en
parfaite santé mais que pour des raisons
inexplicables
elle est en train de mourir tout ceci
est mis sur le dos de l'amour khanaqinne
est passé du mauvais côté et a essayé de
tuer padmé cependant un double sens se
cache ici pourquoi palpatine n'aurait
pas tout simplement tuer cette dernière
il a donné des visions exactes de la
mort de padmé à anakin qui correspond
parfaitement au décès de cette dernière
de plus elle est en parfaite santé mais
pourtant elle est en train de mourir je
vous rappelle que palpatine fut
l'apprenti de dark plagueis donc il sait
maîtriser la force
à tel point de contrôle et la vie et la
mort d'autrui mais par son pouvoir
politique
si douce tôt de garder une certaine
image enfin s'il sait contrôler la vie
et la mort palpatine aurait donc donné
la mort a pas deux mais la reine amidala
et donner naissance à dark vador son
futur apprenti et seigneur sith
j'espère que ces théories vous auront
plus vous avez été nombreux à voter au
précédent sondage pour que je fasse de
nouvelles théories sur la saga star wars
n'oubliez pas le petit pouce bleus qui
me soutient réellement dans mon émission
et à me donner votre avis dans les
commentaires que le line up soit avec
vous cet argot rock
à quel âge a le public en amérique qui
va voir ce film à tous les âges tous les
ans ou c'est pour les enfants de 6 ans
et 70 79 des noms de vous nous fait
l'amitié de faire l'effort de parler
français et ça va très bien comme ça oui
donc public de tout âge alors pour tout
jeune comédienne qui commençait est ce
que c'est un rôle ce rôle de la
princesse est ce que ce n'est pas la
fois un rôle qui risquent de promouvoir
votre carrière ou un rôle dangereux
parce qu'on va toujours vous identifier
à la petite princesse de la guerre des
étoiles est ce que vous n'avez pas peur
que ce n'est pas
asenjo que j'ai fait c'est presque ses
traits avec modestie avec les cheveux
comme ça mais on s'en réjouit car la
douleur vous coiffer de cette façon dans
steam 40 c'est vrai que la coiffure
était différent pour nous reconnaît pas
comme ça est-ce que les gens vous
reconnaissent en amérique a d'ailleurs
porté au progrès et c'est toi qui est le
mien indiqué
en quelques pas mais fait beaucoup
[Musique]